all allora se mi devi scrivere i
controlli per come si gioca visto che
gioco a giochini le palle da tipo 78
anni so come muovermi meglio nei
videogiochi che nella vita reale capito
grazie del menu che mi spiega grazie
mille
volevo farla introverso gioco ha già
caricato bene quindi niente intro oggi
colpa del gioco non prendetela con me
siamo in un posto che non è camera mia
vabbè andiamo avanti ragazzi bank
seniori quebec ma che chi è un corso di
donna questo c'è anche le gambe pensate
sulla nota c'è scritto non mi piace
questo posto e perché no è così allegro
comunque non sono un maniaco non
tocchiamo queste cose grazie molto
gentile c'è un'uscita da qualche parte
dal che peraltro non possono anche
correre ma la massima velocità ragazzi e
questa mia nonna quando va in bagno
uguale ho trovato una chiave lo sapevo
lo stavo per dire giuro meno male che mi
hai anticipato toward a salve
ho giocato tante volte a giochi di
manichini che mi donne che si alzano e
vogliono far parte le chiappe quindi non
sarebbe la prima volta sei molto carina
comunque un po pelata però sei carina
ok continua a pregare zia bravissima
avrei bisogno di un po meno compagnia
però grazie per esservi preoccupati
salve
ecco in questo caso dovresti mettere la
testa a posto e non è una battuta
possono da astori giro questa è la
storia di jerome posso giudizio di
feriti perfetto bene allora mi piace
questo gioco e allegro l'uscita è chiusa
ma guarda un po non l'avrei mai detto
giuro salve cos'è il feticismo in
plastica 2018 arca vacca
ma quello è un carpe mio falegname con
duemila lire e lo fa meglio ragazzini mi
fa molto piacere che mi indichiate la
strada però state con le mani a posto e
grazie
la chiave moriva veloce veloce loach è
successo qualcosa un terremoto non lo so
ho salve molto bello salve salve serve
che cosa sta succedendo
stai como dal i ragazzi non so che cosa
sia successo ma c'è un rumore
stranissimo che è questo che non mi sta
piacendo per tu sei la più bella di
tutte sappia via via via vado benissimo
così da la smettiamo con manichini
dobbiamo muoverci aspetta che leggo però
sappiamo dei tuoi problemi se sapete che
mi fanno schifo i manichini nome di
mettete e stavo dicendo
questi siete voi durante la verifica di
matematica mi fate la cortesia di rime
end of the prison rewind e finito così
egli fatto buttare cinque minuti la mia
vita così spiega me e non si chiude
neanche il gioco lo fai control alt canc
macché problemi la fede nella vita
facciamo un cambio di gioco vediamo se
starò ma un po meglio ora online game by
carlo c
carlo cracco era una donna una che
brutto lampadario madonna mia santa ma
posso muovermi già poi trascinati
trascinati aiuto ho capito preserve
acquirente tua nonna morta e non è bello
perché mi devo far partire sempre in
punti strani ma qual è il vostro
problema non so dove sia moriri preciso
che che sta scivolando qua da non e
mezza che fastidio mi servirebbe una
torcia scusate un attimo nor avevano
pedoni e madonna che buia staccava nelle
tre ci sta qui come quella luce le luci
si sono laila che non ci sono aperto
pure l'armadio mamma mia area per sf
toccacelo la torcia quindi o amen
no ragazzi veramente senza la torcia non
si vede nulla a questo il bagno che
cos'è che sta scivolando da un ora e
mezza mi dà un fastidio ve lo spacco in
testa qualunque cosa sia
qua ci sono i panni sporchi e questo
la porta sembra essere bloccata e tua
sorella è bloccata che ne so io dai raga
minchia non puoi aprire questa porta
bene qualcuno mi dice dove dobbiamo
andare a quest'ora ci sono le luci
questo fastidio madonna chihuahua magno
largo che andò male
minchia raga quanto spazio a gare
possiamo andare avanti da qualche parte
c'è l'uscita qua chiusa magari magari la
chiave stati sopra è mai visto per sé
una porta chiusa
ma i pelati il film dove si lavano la
faccia e che sta sbattendo il proprio
pene contro qualche armadio ora morirai
macché ospitalità ma che bello che bello
così tanta amicizia nell'aria piega il
mana che sbatte la porta e orlando che
chi sta sbattendo le paure ma basta
basta sbattere le porte
c'è qualche problema di fondo però va
bene c'è una sedia ciao sedia
sta passando un treno visto corridoio
sì
mica e paura tu sei sta roba perché mi
spiega o la monna lisa
ecco questo fa ancora più paura se
qualcuno mi da miss piggy cos'è tipo
donnie darko
maronna rocard che mi sono caricato sul
serio non me l'aspettavo mai alla fine
del gioco a questo punto non ho capito
un pene per ok grazie carlo ci sei stato
meraviglioso giuro fortuna che nessuno
di questi due giochi l'ho pagato grazie
a dio ragazzuoli spero che vi sia
piaciuto concludo quale episodi di oggi
spero che questi due horror siano stati
vostro gradimento tua sete ragazzi si
vede più il momento mi piace anche
valigia c'erano almeno sviziare senso
che si siede noi ci vediamo al prossimo
video ricordatevi carlo ci si è
impegnato per fare questo gioco quindi
mette d'élite solo per carlucci non per
me da ragazzo
[Musica]